HAILEE STEINFELD
In our new series, Hawkeye,
Jeremy and I both
play expert archers.
JEREMY RENNER
And while we're not
expert archers in real life,
we do happen to be expert wrappers.
HAILEE STEINFELD
Not that kind of rapper.
JEREMY RENNER
Yeah, expert gift wrappers.
HAILEE STEINFELD
Yes. And right now, we're going to compete
to see who can do a
better job wrapping a Christmas present.
JEREMY RENNER
Let's do this.
Watch and learn.
I don't need this.
- Oh, I got it.
- This is pretty good.
- You alright?
- That little stamp.
JEREMY RENNER
Some tape.
- Alright.
- Okay.
JEREMY RENNER
Are you ready? Wait, hold on a second.
Okay. Merry Christmas.
HAILEE STEINFELD
Wow! Call it a draw?
JEREMY RENNER
Well, whatever's inside is broken anyway,
so, what are you gonna do...
- It's the outside that counts. Right?
- Just the box. Okay.
HAILEE STEINFELD
Perfect. It's the outside that counts.